so one thing that you've done that I
really appreciate because it comes
completely with the spirit of how I've
done this show is you've really tried to
build bridges with people that perhaps
some might think you shouldn't get along
with or you shouldn't talk with so I've
seen you a couple times with Glenn Beck
and and I was tweeting up a storm the
first time I saw it because I thought
this is exactly what the news is
supposed to be this is what not not
reporting but this is what conversation
is supposed to be you guys come from
very different places you know he's a
pure libertarian I suppose your politics
are different and you know you're just
trying to have the conversation and
that's what I'm trying to do here and I
thought it was pretty beautiful
so I guess I don't even know my question
is as much as I want to see more of that
what you say then our politics are
different I'm not political I'm like the
least political person that you swear I
don't care about conservative or liberal
I think all politicians are full of it I
think and I judge things on my own so
you know and especially coming from an
african-american background
african-americans are pretty liberal and
some things and also very conservative
and many times conservative socially
when it comes to the church yeah so you
know you know for people to sit there
and pretend like oh where are those big
liberals and they're not and then you
don't accept gay people and then it's so
it's it's not true so I'm not I I am NOT
political so when you say my politics
are different it's not I will listen I
think the only way especially if it's
someone you don't agree with or if you
consider them your enemy or not on your
side don't you want to know what they're
thinking I don't understand what people
say I am never gonna talk to them how
could you don't you dare sit down you
know how much crap I got because I like
I because I sat down twice Aaron Wilson
and I went I almost got the interviews
between me George Stephanopoulos and one
other person
I forget who it was and we we almost you
know George ended up getting the
interview I got so much gut because I
wanted to do an interview with him it's
like well don't you want to
hear from him Nick even if you don't
agree with him especially if you don't
agree with him you want to hear his
rationale and his reasoning so it has
never made sense to me to not talk to
someone who you disagree with now that
said I think that people should be
respectful and they should be in their
right minds you know before you when
you're talking to them and if they don't
then they're out of here I'll cut you
right off yeah yeah if you're being an
ignoramus I'm not dealing with it yeah
well interestingly I wasn't even going
to bring this up but a couple months ago
maybe two months ago or so you had Sam
Harris who's been on my show who's
become a friend of mine and Dean
Obeidallah were on and they were they
were debating this Islam and and sort of
you know religion verse people thing and
in the midst of it Dean said something
that I knew to be a you know implying
that Sam believed something about all
Muslims and I knew it to be not true
because I had sat there with Sam and
rehashed it he's rehash that a thousand
times
and while it was infuriating for me to
watch I thought all right
at least they're having the conversation
so that's what you're just opening the
door for yeah and the the thing about
that is is that we have to stop calling
people you know isms or Oh Oh B is
phobias homophobic or Islamophobic
whatever because they want to have a
conversation that's part that's what we
do yeah is have a conversation and when
you have great minds like you know a
freed zakaria or sam harris or who
member who say yes there is a problem
that must be addressed in islam and we
have to figure out how to do it when you
have great minds like that those are the
people that you should listen to and you
get people who say there is no problem
and by you saying this then you are
Islamophobic then that person is very
dangerous because the evidence is there
doesn't mean that people in that
religion or bad it doesn't mean that it
that Islam is bad doesn't mean that
Muslims are bad doesn't mean that
because we talk about crime in Chicago
that is committed mostly by African
Americans it doesn't mean that African
Americans are bad or that black people
are bad it means that we're just having
those conversations and so we have to
stop that and you know that's I think
that's why I can talk to someone like a
Glenn Beck is because you know I
I would rather have common ground with
people or try to reach some sort of
common ground or consensus rather than
just having them an enemy keeping them
at arm's length and not being at the
table that's what's happening in
Washington with the Congress right now
what good is that doing anybody yeah so
that's actually a perfect segue for the
political climate so let's just talk
about that a little bit so you've been
in this for a while
it's pretty bad right now right like
could it get much worse I keep thinking
that it's not gonna get much worse and
now I realize we're in an election year
we've got this crazy thing with Trump
right now that's me yeah you just have
to nod through this whole thing probably
but really like how much worse is this
thing gonna get before this election
comes I think it's gonna get a lot worse
and I think because of how much it's
being amped up on both sides so
whoever's in the White House next is
gonna have a huge challenge like if a
Democrat is in there all those people
that have been revved up by the ride and
by Donald Trump some people you just go
Hillary Clinton ago you say Donald Trump
they go oh my god you can't even get
their name out so I think people are
becoming amped up more than almost any
election that I've seen except for
during the Obama election it was pretty
it was pretty crazy right him and Sarah
Palin it was like wow what in a weird
way doesn't it seem like to me it seems
like we were all on ecstasy back then
like it was like we just romanticized it
had it was bad yeah I mean come on it
was you know he wasn't he wasn't America
and he was a Muslim he went to a
madrasah what else oh you know air
socialist thought a socialist all those
things and then you know McCain couldn't
find a running mate and then he found
Sarah Palin and that was a disaster and
then people said oh my god everybody was
out to get Sarah Palin and then as it
turns out she was not as informed as she
should have been and so it was you know
it was a little crazy right all that
said we didn't have a trump right how do
you deal with this Trump thing because
one of the things that I've
and we've talked about a bunch of it I
know I don't necessarily love what he
says that's not don't get me wrong
ya know but the spectacle I love no no I
love interviewing you because you don't
know what he's going to say I love the
back-and-forth I love the way his mind
works doesn't mean I agree with him and
you know when he's like excuse me excuse
me done you know people at home like oh
you cut you off inside I'm kind of
laughing I'm like my gosh and I'm like
hey you know when he goes ah excuse me
done he it's it's a bit comical
sometimes he's a performer so I love
interviewing him but that's about it so
is that really though the secret sauce
to what he's doing that the rest of
these guys all of them pretty much I
would argue that Bernie probably is not
because Bernie does seem like he's
speaking from the heart and he speaks in
a way that doesn't sound like a
politician but pretty much the rest of
them they all just sound like
politicians and people are over that and
and because of that even when Trump says
crazy stuff it makes people like him
like there's where we have this like
thing that's like eating itself
constantly with him and because of that
I mean I tell people this because that
usually ticked them off right I usually
tell like people who are on the Left
president Truong get used to Italy oh
but it's you know I had never I had not
underestimated him since he got into the
race because here's why and I said this
from the beginning you can probably find
it on tape somewhere he's used to
swimming in these New York media waters
sharks right he knows how to handle and
manipulate the media he knows how to cut
a deal you know if you can when they say
if you can make it there you can make it
anywhere this guy's made as I help from
his dad don't get me wrong but you know
he he's made it here he's become you
know at the top of the sort of food
chain and the media food chain here he
knows how to deal with the media and so
and he's got a lot of money a lot of it
of running for president is having a ton
of dough and he has a ton of dough and
he knows how to deal with people and he
has a good ear on what people want to
hear so when he's in front of a crowd
he's like oh they like that huh and he
gets him boy oh they don't like that so
much he changes the subject
so having known all of that and being
here in the 90s and and knowing Donald
Trump was like this guy isn't going
anywhere so yeah yeah all right I got
just a couple more for you because I
know you have to actually be mom you
know you have to be live on air not too
not too long for now and about two hours
and oh I got plenty
I'll go listen I'll talk as long as you
want to how much do you think I'm one of
my major issues is when I watch
something live by the way no we're not
like we're not going when I watch
something like the you know the Press
Club the yearly thing where the media
gets together and roasts the politicians
and all what's it called at the Press
Club the corresponding White House
Correspondents Dinner Thanks
when I watch all of this stuff and even
I saw you a couple weeks ago at the in
the spin room at the debate in Vegas we
were at the democratic debate there and
I've been around it a little more lately
one of the things that I really do fear
is that the the media and the
politicians are just in it too tightly
that people are just too friendly with
each other they're actually you know
they're we have so many instances of
people that are married to people on
television and they're the kids and this
one or the uncle of that one on all of
this stuff I'm pretty sure you're no one
in your families pulling strings in
politics right let's get that out of the
way
except for my cousin Brock but that's of
course he's your cousin of course these
guys are right but really how do you see
that as an actual threat to democracy
because that I really see as a major
problem I don't know if I would call it
a threat to democracy I do see it as um
it's a little fake and phony to me but
you know it was great going to you know
being invited to the White House
correspondent center but it was a lot
more fun when I was covering and that
can make fun of people right so how much
does that make you bite your tongue
because you want to go to the dinners
right like we've all been around to the
White House Christmas party right and
because I knew the Obamas from Chicago
and it was it's tough and I've said this
before like when you know someone people
I didn't know them that well
my best friends but I knew them from
around the way right from being I was a
local news anchor and they were there
there was you know I would introduce
them at you know chicken dinners like a
mellow State Senator Barack Obama show
and then his wife would always say Oh
Don stay out of trouble and I'm like who
me why so to have to sort of criticize
him on policy and things was it was at
first it was uncomfortable I'm like oh
he's the president and the buck stops
with him so I've got it you know and
he's black or whatever I've got to do it
I'm a journalist that was I I took a
note and so when I saw him sort of in a
in an informal context and not like
throwing questions at him or seeing him
at NABJ and like yelling across the room
like how are you gonna handle this and
having him yell back when I had to go
and like shake their hand and take a
picture with him I was like oh you know
and they were like hey you know you did
the right thing by coming out and I was
like thank you right and so they get it
they get it but it was a little weird
and I felt like I don't know if I should
be that close to when in this sort of
situation to be partying with the
president or for that matter of partying
with some of the people you know when
you go to the Oscars and all those
things I don't know I just feel like I
kind of feel like Wendy Williams right
who sits in her purple chair and she
like talks smack about everybody and
then when they see her or when she sees
it she's like oh I kind of feel like
that a little bit so yeah but don't you
think don't you think that more you guys
need that sense because I totally feel
like everybody you know and it's not
just I don't mean just there at the
friendly level but you know we don't
have to I'm not trying to you know name
names or out people here but there are
plenty of anchors that literally used to
work on campaigns for for president yeah
or I mean you can name some names it
look weird to me look I mean somebody
like you know right there is Diane
Sawyer there's George Will I mean even
in George Will as a commentator David
Gregg and he's a commentator Donna
Brazile commentator that's different but
when you're a journalist you know there
are plenty of journalists who have
worked for campaigns yeah but when
you're a commentator how different do
you actually think that is so somebody
like Donald a it's good but don't you
think they have a certain amount of
legions for a campaign that they
that they worked on previously that they
you know I think they do that's why we
hire them yeah because they not because
they have Allegiance because they have
knowledge to that person or we will say
Donna Brazile worked for the Al Gore
campaign you everybody knows that so she
can offer insight but also we have we
with unless you're crazy you know that
her allegiance would be to you know to
Al Gore yeah III think it's totally
different because when you're a
commentator you're hired
to commentate as they say or to comment
and to give your opinion as a journalist
you're not necessarily that's not your
role yeah but you're pretty much right I
would say you're right in between those
two things I do on CNN what I do is I do
in more of a point of view on I am hired
as to give commentary on the time Joyner
Morning Show radio show which had to be
approved by CNN so I feel free and
different in that zone to give but when
I'm on CNN I have to watch myself
because that's not exactly what you know
I do but everyone has a certain lens and
everyone has a certain background and
they have a point of view and I think
that's okay as a human being as long as
you let people know that and but that's
nothing new
you know Murrow Cronkite all those guys
gave commentary right well I always do
you think that's funny when you know
some of these people on TV will say well
I don't share any of my opinions and
it's like that's pretty much impossible
actually yeah even if for no other
reason than your body language when
you're talking to somebody right yeah
yeah absolutely
yeah anything wrong with it especially
if you declare it that's why I had you
know when people were saying the fox is
to the right okay fine they let you know
MSNBC is to the left okay fine they let
you know and we are neither here we want
to be objective at CNN but we don't want
people to run our objectivity to let
people run all over reality and truth
know yeah so I should tell everybody
that right before we started the
recording here you said to me what are
we gonna talk about and I said to you
that I knew with you I wasn't gonna have
to you know a lot of times I'll tell
them I guess we're gonna touch on these
kind of things but I knew with you that
you were gonna be cool with that so I
hope that that alone I want my audience
to know that because I
that alone will dispel some of this
stuff about sort of how a lot of you
guys have to operate or at least how you
have to operate because because the
person that I know off the camera is the
same guy that I know right the second
yeah yeah I there you go
and I don't want to know the exact
questions you're gonna ask me and most
of that was just like hey what are we
gonna talk about what's going on it was
no you didn't you didn't push me at all
hey don't do that or I'm gonna get mad
ya know and we don't do that with our
subjects either like someone we're gonna
go interview we don't give them the
questions I mean they'll say what are we
gonna talk about we're talking about you
running for president that's a word yeah
give me give me like your worst moment
with a candidate like what's like the
worst thing that's ever any real flub or
did you ever really offend anybody or
anything like that no I mean one of the
one of the most contentious moments was
with Rand Paul I'm sure you remember
that and I started this whole thing
called no talking points yeah because I
hate talking points and I hate the way
politicians answer questions so ask me a
question just a simple question and I'm
gonna be a politician done is that your
office that you're in right now well
when you talk about opposite the
grandmother taught me was that you don't
really own anything it's all shared and
it's all part of the the American people
own everything right and then you're
just like okay are you gonna answer the
damn question yeah so the simple answer
is yes this is my office
politicians have a hard time doing that
so Rand Paul had did that with me I was
just like I'm like look man
could you stop telling me what you did
yesterday in Congress and what you did
how do you feel about this do you hear
the question that I'm asking you and so
then he got really upset we it became
really heated and so it was an
uncomfortable moment but it was also a
very freeing moment to me because I was
like you know what you know what it I'm
sick of this and so I set a marker there
and so everyone I had that came on had
to answer the question and they do now
now I'm not gonna badger people because
sometimes they just won't and I'll say
okay and then I will say it is obvious
that you don't want to answer the
question so we will move on right
because I don't want to waste the
audience time so that was probably an
uncomfortable moment that I had with a
candidate but then I just interviewed
him too
three hours ago so it's all it's all
good yeah do you ever bite your tongue
though related to the fact that you want
these guys to come on again because even
when I was in the spin room talking to
talking to their representatives not
even the candidates I did feel a little
bit of you know I had Huckabee's
campaign already come back on there at
the end of the day for you but they all
want to be on CNN fair enough oh but yes
I know where you're going with this and
the thing is it's not it's not so let me
share a little secret with you all right
this is just between us this is just
between us yeah so if you have that
concern your head and that's a very real
concern and that and that's real because
you do want people to come back right so
it's all in the way you ask the question
it's all in the tone if I say dig why
are you such a damn bleeding-heart
liberal you'll go what do you mean so
you can just go well you know that's a
very liberal perspective why why do you
feel that way
yeah it's the same question right pretty
much it's all in the way you ask it it's
like asking a question with a smile on
your face it's all in the tone and you
can do it by complimenting and say I
know you pride yourself on your politics
in your liberalism so would you answer
this question for me it's the same thing
yeah well that's the fun you ask the
question that sort of brings it back to
where we started this sort of online
verse mainstream media thing because
I'll see a lot of times you know the
online guys who aren't interviewing
these people who are just commentating
on it they'll be like lemon didn't
attack him for this or he didn't do this
or that and it's like well guess what
he's the one that actually has to stand
there do it get another interview in the
future you know figure out how to get
truth from people that aren't going to
give you much truth so my point is it's
it's easier said than done here's the
thing it is it's not and it's not even
that it's easier for them to say it
because their way is not necessarily the
best way or the easiest way because you
want someone to continue to sit there in
the interview to answer questions right
and you you also want you don't want to
antagonize them and I'm also thinking
about the viewer because if I continue
to antagonize them the viewer gets no
information that person shuts down and
it's not good for any of us yeah right
so it's done so rather than what am I
going to do
stand up go over to the chair that the
subject is sitting in and
wring their neck it's not it's not gonna
happen so if you're if you're sitting
there Dave Rubin and you don't want to
answer a question what am I gonna do
inject you with would you call it sodium
pentathol yeah to make you tell the
truth it's not gonna happen so you get
as much as you can and then you move on
yeah that's how it works all right I got
one more for you but first have you ever
touched wolf blitzer's beard I feel like
I'd really watch it today in that way it
was we gave each other a TV hug and it
was a little weird like oh yeah I'm
convinced there's something there's
something like the whole secret to
success is the beard it's mad it's magic
OOP be on my show at 10:00 p.m. so you
have to watch oh nice all right cool all
right well then my my last question for
you is what's next cuz I've seen this
thing not to talk about the rise that
you didn't want to talk about before but
but I've seen it I flat out seen it so
what's next man so I'm sure you've read
well so here's the thing
people always ask me Oh what are you
gonna do next what's your do you know
how long I fought to get where I am so
I'm just gonna love this for a while
like I really I wake up every day and
usually you know sometimes the first
time I wake up is because an alarm goes
off and it's time for my editorial call
and the first thing that's on my mind
every day as well what am I gonna put on
TV today that is pretty freakin awesome
so I'm in a really great spot I live
every moment in gratitude I am very
happy I'm content
I'm not complacent so I'm gonna enjoy
this for the moment and I would have to
say that the next thing if I could think
about it but best laid plans right it's
probably a show that is more Bill Maher
or Chelsea Handler ish or something like
that where I can actually give a point
of view and actually say like you said
[ __ ] or whatever it is that you said
right and not have everybody go oh my
gosh you can't I can't believe Don Lemon
said that right well they're probably
gonna do that either way but yeah that's
probably if I had to think of something
but who
I will probably do this if all goes as
it's going now knock on wood
you know God allow for the next 10 or 15
years and that's not a bad thing
yeah well listen I a hundred percent you
know how thrilled I am for your success
in our friendship and I look forward to
our next adventure at Blondie's you you
can down some wings you you put me to
shame
I mean it was said I had to cut back I
was there this weekend past weekend yeah
I only ate eight of my ten wings oh yeah
I've ordered like to order double orders
when we've been yeah you literally you
got a double order you had I think 48
wings on a plate no let me tell you this
let me tell you um I used to be able to
do that in my 20s and 30s and 40s and
now I can't do it wait did you hit the
big five oh I thought I don't want to
hear it oh no why are you turned five oh
I'm a little behind you how far I'm 39
oh wow you're you're older than me I'm
37 wait a minute something ain't right
here anyway you guys can catch Don
weeknights on CNN and pretty much
wherever and whenever
breaking news happens Don thanks a lot
man thanks good to see you did you take
the good work